what do you want to do with your life
don't have a clue there are loads of
possibilities yes okay making that first
move from school or college to the world
of work is tough but you've just got to
know where and how to look to get off to
a good start maybe you're like Peter
what's his story well he was 16 when he
started looking for a job in his own
country what he really needed was
information guidance training
opportunities and access to employers
good choices for him were private
recruitment agencies and public
employment services in fact public
employment services are really useful if
you're looking for help online by phone
or viral walk in office as their network
has more than 5,000 offices in 31
countries across Europe plus they also
have a team of uris advisors who can
help if you'd prefer to work in another
EU country in which case you more like
Gabriella who at age 18 decided she
wanted to work abroad the your first
uris job scheme was perfect for her as
it is designed to help young people find
a job elsewhere in Europe it seeks to
match job seeker profiles with existing
vacancies and companies in other
countries helps to complete applications
provides interview tips and so on it can
even contribute cash towards an
interview trip or for when you move
abroad to work or maybe the sort of
slaving away for someone else all your
life just doesn't cut it then you're
like Sarah who when she was 17 already
saw herself as an entrepreneur and had
some fantastic ideas for her own
business but first she wanted to gain
some skills and experience on the job by
working for an SME a small and
medium-sized enterprise as a springboard
to setting up her own company in the
future Sarah came across some really
useful schemes in her own country which
also exists europe-wide these provide
all sorts of support including access to
potential employers and
funding opportunities such as
microfinance so back to you are you
feeling more excited by the many avenues
open to you well good because the job
market in Europe really does want your
skills your ideas and energy no matter
your background experience or
qualifications so what are you waiting
for don't hesitate take your first step
into your future your first job is
closer than you think
you